Mort Kondracke author of saving Mellie
what's your book about it's a love story
it's it's a history of the Parkinson's
movement the effort to get more money
spent by the federal government on
research on Parkinson's which is a
disease that neurologists say could be
cured it's a story of it's a kind of a
personal transformation story of
somebody who looked was basically a
journalistic careerist to somebody who
decided that best thing he could do with
his life was to help Millie help my wife
my wife is a truly remarkable person I
mean everybody all the friends that I
talked to say everybody became a better
person because of Mellie she was a
dynamic therapist psychotherapist mother
wife strong person and she's been you
know basically kidnapped by parkinson's
disease which is in the process of
killing her and I wanted to write about
this whole experience when did you
decide to do the book two years ago two
and a half years ago something like that
I have been living this experience I
mean it's the combination of watching
her suffer with it and fight it through
surgeries and all kinds of stuff and and
fight and try to fight it by trying to
get more money raised for Parkinson's
research and and we we Millie and I both
have this therapist friend of ours Dorie
Lynn who said you know you've just
you've got to write about this and and
I'd never written a book before and I so
I started and one thing led to another
and here the book is finally out as I
read it I kept saying to myself why does
Mort Kondracke want us to know all this
meaning all the little things that we
can talk about because this is a
horrible nasty lousy rotten fiendish
disease which the best neurologists in
the country say can be cured in five to
ten years if a dacoit resources are
devoted to the task I mean and and that
in the process of
making Parkinson's disease you would
find things which would cure
Huntington's disease and Alzheimer's and
ALS all kinds of neurodegenerative
diseases so I the best way to get people
to say yeah let's fund neurodegenerative
research was to tell it all just as bad
as it is and let them know what what
really happens and also let him know
that there's hope okay give me an
example I've known you probably thirty
years I had no idea you were not calling
hmm why do you want us to know that well
that's part of what Millie did I mean
Millie Millie was the kind of person I
was an alcoholic and I was you know I
wasn't stumbling down drunk called all
day long I didn't drink till after hours
but it clearly at like George W Bush got
in my way a lot and uh and Millie was
such a powerhouse that she made me quit
I mean she said you are an alcoholic I
fought that she convinced me that I was
an alcoholic and she basically she
dumped the booze out out and down the
drain and stuff like that and just
badgered me and till the point
intervened as they say and got me to to
quit and it's part of her old power and
it's part it's one of the wonderful
stories that I have to tell about about
what kind of a person she was but you
say that you didn't start drinking too
much and so you get to this town yeah
that's true well well I think I have
that I have a gene and some it does run
in families and my father was an
alcoholic and his father was an
alcoholic and his brother was an
alcoholic and it became a habit and and
I was anesthetize myself I'm sure I was
sort of neurotic about you know climbing
the greasy pole as a journalist and and
you know I made it to a certain level
but I you know looked up and there were
lots of people above me and I'm sure
that I was you know that it that it was
a combination of things it was partly
hereditary partly partly to avoid you
know the the pain of what I wasn't
succeeding at and all this kind of stuff
so I can't blame it on Washington I
probably would have been an alcoholic no
matter where I lived when did you quit
1986 right right after Thanksgiving 1986
you also go into some detail in here
about the early days of your politics
mm-hmm and at one point you say I gave
up being a liberal Democrat because of
foreign policy I was I was never very
partisan I mean I sort of leaned
democrat because I was I had a liberal
view of the world as I think 80% of
journalists do probably I was Pro civil
rights I was you know and I just took I
just took the liberal view of
practically everything that that anybody
who wasn't for expanding government I
remember arguing with remember Charlie
Goodell was a senator from from New York
and once upon a time he was a
representative from New York and was
sort of the chief Republican critic of
the war on poverty and if he was
anything that he criticized on the
management of the war on poverty meant
that he was against the war on poverty
therefore he was against poor people
right and that's just the way I thought
what what happened was I was covering
the White House in nineteen in that the
Ford White House and I'll never forget
1974 the the the South Vietnamese are
fighting for their lives right right at
the very end
the North Vietnamese are descending on
them and Ford proposed six hundred
million dollars in emergency aid for the
South Vietnamese to keep them going and
Congress refused and I thought what do
Democrats do but spend money you know I
mean to bolster an ally and save them
from what amounted to slavery you know
Congress wouldn't vote this money and I
just thought you know the there's this
is wrong and and I I just thought that
that on occasion after occasion after
that I just thought that the Democrats
if it were up to the Democrats we we
wouldn't fight communism the way it
needed to be fought that it was that it
really was an evil empire and that it
needed to be resisted and the Liberals
weren't doing it they didn't do it in
Central America and so
and I just fell out with them there were
other things as well I mean I I'm a
prude
I confess it I'm a you know and and I
think that our society has become
grotesquely coarsened and I think
liberals have been basically cheering it
the whole way you know anything goes
kitties you know teenagers are gonna
have sex so give the little dairies
condoms and stuff like that and it's
just sort of encouraged the corseting of
society so but I'm not a conservative I
mean I may sound like conservative right
now but I'm not really a conservative
cuz I have my problems with them too so
I found my happy home in moderation
which is where I'm I am she say Milly is
quite liberal Milly she's not that
liberal she's a dot she has a
dyed-in-the-wool Democrat and you know
Democrats as a body can do very little
wrong and Republicans buy her and do
very little right and it's almost a joke
with us although she
I mean she's not she hasn't lost her
judgment completely I mean she was
disappointed in Bill Clinton but she but
she also apologized for him you know
Bill Clinton live do you say lied to you
and Hillary Clinton lied to you
yeah substantially a Bill Clinton didn't
precisely lie what this is a story that
I tell in the book about we went to a
Christmas White House Christmas party
hoping that we could get them to do
something to advance Parkinson's
research because it was it's deeply
underfunded by comparison with other
diseases and and as I say it's believed
to be curable so we practice the
practice of the speeches we're going in
line that in the in the line to see the
president and I blew the speech
completely and she did too but we got
out enough to say you know please help
brain research and Hillary Clinton said
well just wait till we pass health care
reform we're going to do a lot for
medical research well the one there was
nothing in the health reform plan for
Parkinson's research neurological
research or much of any kind of research
and secondly
both of them made claims about their the
in about inquiry the increasing medical
research that they never really
delivered on I mean what what kept
happening is that certain Republicans
basically Connie Mack of Florida John
Porter of Illinois Arlen Specter of
Pennsylvania and also some Democrats Tom
Harkin of Iowa kept increasing the
medical research budget in Congress and
Clinton would sign the bill and then
pretend that he had advocated it all
along but whenever his budgets came in
they were always lowball two percent
increases three percent increases
sometimes negative
I mean sometimes net cuts after
inflation stuff like that so he
certainly he didn't stand in the way of
medical research advances but he
certainly did not promote them with the
exception of certain politically favored
projects like AIDS research and breast
cancer and to his credit the human
genome project that he did he didn't
Vance
what's Parkinson's Parkinson's is a
disease that's caused it's a brain
disease it's caused by the the dying of
a little clump of cells deep in your
brain called the substantial [ __ ] which
produced dopamine dopamine is the
substance that makes motion fluid and it
the first symptoms are usually our
slight tremor in your in a finger and it
goes on to rigidity people get frozen in
a chair some some people have them
develop a mask they have no they can't
express any anything in their faces and
eventually eventually you become
immobile you know you can be you
basically you become a prisoner in your
own body it's treatable for about five
years I mean you can see it in Janet
Reno Janet Reno has a severe tremor I
guess it's in her left hand a medicine
called l-dopa cinnamon is the brand name
will calm that symptom down for about
five years and then it stops working
and then people get frozen or they get
something called dyskinesia anybody who
ever saw the movie awakenings you know
they get wild shakes of the body are
dyskinesia that are caused by the
medicine itself actually and you know in
awakenings people would rather go to
sleep then and be in a coma then have
these well dyskinesia so it's it's a
wretched disease and eventually and in
in Millie's case what's happening is
that she's losing her she can't walk she
lost her balance a long time ago and she
fell repeatedly and had to go to the
emergency room a lot and so on now she's
confined to a wheelchair and she's
basically losing her has lost her
ability to speak and the the horrible
thing is that she's losing her ability
to swallow and that will we're gonna be
faced with the decision at some point
about a feeding tube I mean that that's
what happens what age does it affect you
it used to be in old people's disease
it's now Michael J Fox got it when he
was 30 and you know there were people
get it when their 20s and nobody knows
why at the age of onset is descend
average age of onset is descending
people think it's environmental
chemicals that nobody knows for sure why
some time ago I think 96 she did an
article about mo Udall again why
well actually the Washingtonian magazine
asked me to write an article about Janet
Reno when she was diagnosed and she
refused to cooperate because she wanted
to be known as as Attorney General not
as a Parkinson's victim so and Billy
Graham was thought to have Parkinson's
and didn't didn't he didn't as it turned
out he had something else but he didn't
want to cooperate the Pope was too far
away so I wrote about Millie and about
mo Udall and mo Udall this wonderful
funny presidential candidate that
everybody loves and still quotes these
hilarious jokes from Goddard in 1996
when he was running for president kept
in his 19 I was 77 1976 when he was
running for president
kept it a secret but eventually it
caught up with her men and in 1991 he
fell and he got a brain concussion he
broke ribs clavicle collarbone all kinds
of shoulder blade every you know just
and never never was able to speak again
was confined to a to the Veterans
Administration Hospital not far from the
Capitol and his story was the worst case
of Parkinson's that I knew of
certainly involving a famous person and
I went to see him and and he was a
prisoner in his body and his wife didn't
know whether when she talked to him he
understood anything and this was a kind
of a foretaste I've feared and the
reality is coming true that of what
milling faces I mean that was 1996
this is took five years later and Millie
is not is not is not as bad as mo Udall
was then but unless there's a miracle of
some sort is headed in that direction I
fear when you went there you found a
guest book that had been signed by oh by
first ladies Barbara Bush Hillary Rodham
Clinton most of all most the most
frequent visitor was John McCain who had
been adopted sort of by mo Udall when he
was a freshman congressman he was a
Republican they're both Mehra's own
obviously McCain was a freshman
Republican most junior member of the
interior committee but man mo was the
chairman and mo Udall adopted him
basically took him under his wing and
helped him a lot and and John McCain
returned the favor by being the most
loyal visitor to mo you don't whether he
couldn't communicate but McCain was
great about visiting him when you went
to see him what did you see he was
asleep
his wife Norma woke him up he sort of
sat up I got gating I'm trying to
remember whether he sat up by himself
where she helped him up but anyway he
sat up and he said he only had one eye
anyway
and he sort of there was sort of a look
of mild recognition I'd you know seen
him and interviewed him various times
over the years but you got you you got
the look of a politician you know
thinking that he may recognize this
person that a constituent that he ought
to know whose name you ought to know but
you couldn't tell so I just sort of told
him stories about what was happening
politically and it and couldn't really
tell whether he understood or not and
after a few minutes he went fell back to
sleep how long was he in that state in
the hospital well from 1991 and he died
in 1998 so he was there first he was
that way for seven years what did his
wife tell you about the disease and the
impact on her well she had she married
him after he had been diagnosed and I
mean she said that he had hallucinations
that's another thing that the medicine
can cause they were they weren't they I
mean it was a thought that there was a
little dog that they didn't have who was
running around the house that that
happens with with l-dopa
it does affect your brain circuits the
medicine itself what else that that he
couldn't that he had to be but it had to
have his food chopped up for him and and
he had to be fed and increasingly
couldn't eat solid foods and that's
happened with Millie too and and his his
internal clock got turned around he had
a mask he he he was virtually
expressionless for a long time
and and had slurred speech which merely
also has had she she took the burden
pretty well I thought you know she was I
mean I said John McCain was his most
frequent visitor obviously she was
because she was she was incredibly loyal
and attentive and present for him right
now what is a day like you for you start
at the very beginning okay Millie wakes
up ahead of me sleeping the same bleep
as they venture
I I get up in the morning I look over
and there she is wide-eyed waiting for
me to wake up and we and she's you know
and I give her a kiss and I say have I
told you lately that I love you and she
says no and I said
and so we laugh and we say okay I love
you you know and then I get up and I get
her her met her first met medicine of
the day is three halves of a cinnamon
tablet plus a medicine called me rep X
and I give it to her with a piece of
chocolate usually she though then that
we then TV goes on Good Morning America
or the Today Show then I go read the
paper or bring give give her some of the
paper and she generally just stays in
bed and that we have we have two ladies
who come one alternate and they
basically take care of her during the
day and I leave and go to work and and I
know she's in safe hands they are
perfectly wonderful I mean I could not I
could not work without them I couldn't
do anything without them and so I then I
don't usually see Millie until again
about 7:30 when I get get home from work
and you know do Fox News and all that
stuff and so Millie's usually had dinner
and is sitting at her favorite green
chair and what I then I go get my dinner
and I sit next to her and I eat my
dinner while TV's on and she's if she's
watching often been watching Fox News
and she will allow as how I have not
been I was not protective enough of you
know Bill Clinton when he was president
or something a joke you know the way she
sometimes she can talk and sometimes you
can actually understand what she's
saying we have computers rigged up all
over the house little computers laptop
computers with it with a full thing that
she will tap out what she basically has
to say to me
and we watch TV together we something on
two days the week I have to write my
column at night so I usually leave her
watching TV and reading and I go into a
by the computer which is in another room
and I checked with her from time to time
and I you know make sure that she's got
her Godiva candy supply and stuff and
you know and we she'll tap out what
she's done during the day and what I
ought to be doing and what I haven't
done I mean it's not she's not a she is
wonderful she's not a she's not a nag
she doesn't she she's basically a jewel
right so but but she reminds me of
things that I have to do and stuff like
that and then we you know go to bed
about eleven or so and you oh she always
wants to call the kids
my daughter's make you know make sure
how they are and she listens in on the
phone line and she tries to talk to them
and then I grabbed the phone and
translate for her with them and or we
call her mother's been sick her foster
mother's been sick in Chicago so we've
been calling a lot out of Chicago I have
more to do on weekends when especially
on Sundays the ladies take off and
basically I'm her caregiver so that I
help her eat you know I cook I she's got
to have her food chopped up or mashed up
and stuff like that in my feed her so
how many times have you given her the
Heimlich maneuver four or I think four
times what brings it about well she's
over ambitious about about things she's
getting less so but but she thinks she
can eat muscles for example or or spare
ribs and she wants to try and you can't
you know sometimes she can actually can
eat it she can eat that stuff and you so
you don't want to say no but she used to
get food gets caught into her throat and
she on four occasions she was gonna
choke to death unless you do the
Heimlich maneuver you know like that and
on each occasion the food came out and
she was gasping for air and stuff like
that it's scary it's terrifying but so
far only four times which isn't and it
hasn't happened for since I believe
since last Thanksgiving I think imagine
your daughter's Andrea and Alex where
are they
Andrea just graduated from Johns Hopkins
Medical School and is gonna do a
residency in Baltimore for one year and
then may become a psychiatrist and my
other daughter Alex is a filmmaker in
New York she got an award at Sundance
Film Festival year before last and is
trying to be Martin Scorsese or Spike
Lee or somebody like that but you you
point out at a moment in the life of you
your wife and your daughters where the
question of whether or not Milly would
die what would happen to the family yeah
I mean there have been two sort of
life-changing moments I mean one way it
was when Milly got diagnosed and I sort
of said to my we can get into this but I
sort of said to myself okay whatever
else I'm doing here on earth this is the
most important thing to do is to take
care of Billy I'd say the second great
life-changing experience was Milly was
was she Millie's had two deep brain
surgeries one is a pallidotomy the other
was is the is an implant of in inner
brain like what amounts to a pacemaker
for your brain the first operation was
in 1995 I think 1995 I think it was and
it was an Emory University Hospital in
Atlanta and we were we were all
naturally terrified about whether the
operation would succeed and whether she
would be okay and so on and so and Alex
was taking moot was doing movies of the
whole thing not she didn't she didn't
get into the operation but she was
taking movies of everybody and recording
everybody's thoughts and stuff like that
and she's so she got
in a room and she said what do you think
would happen if mom died and I said well
I don't know I whether I would I would
certainly be bereft but I don't know
whether I would just go on living or I
would start drinking again or what you
know I don't know what I would do it's
the impossible and I said to her well
what would happen to you and she said
well I'm drea and I talked about that
last night and I said well turn the
camera around and let's record what you
have to say
and she said I'm drea said that our
family would fall apart that we would
never see each other again
that you you meaning me would not want
to have us around and it was like and
and and she said and and I said why do
you think that and she said that mom's
the glue that holds this family together
and if she was gone we'd all fall apart
and the two of them agreed to that and I
was devastated by this and obviously I
realized that I had to be both I had to
start trying to be the glue and and I've
tried and I've really you know I've
bonded with my kids like I never did
before and try and and there's no
question of that anymore
I mean my kids and I are totally bond
enough but it was it was it was a it was
it was a horrible shock I mean it was it
was the ultimate sort of condemnation of
my the way I had been as a father I mean
I was I was I was being a good husband
but I was not being as good a father as
I should be and I resolved that I would
become so what were you doing wrong um I
you know I've always been I was always
eager for their professional success and
nagged them to get good grades and stuff
like that but I mean milly milly was
this incredible magnet for information
for everybody you know and she was just
totally
welded with the kids and the kids talked
to her about the girls talked to her
about everything and after all they are
women right so they had that in common
and they talked about women things and I
was I was career minded and I would talk
to them about their careers and I didn't
talk to them about their feelings and
their you know I guess their ambitions
and hopes and fears and what they cried
about and stuff like that and and I and
it's a matter of attention I guess it's
just and I sort of and I did sort of
leave that stuff to Milly because she
was so good at it you know and I went
off and did my thing and provide you
know provided the money and stuff like
that but I didn't provide the attention
so but I do my best now have anybody
known you over the years would not call
you a great in motor I mean that's just
not been your image but there's more
emotion on one page in this book then I
think I've seen all these years is this
the true Mort Kondracke this is it boy
naked yeah no I I put it all in there I
you know I I feel it and I just and you
know in writing it's I guess it wasn't
easy and I wrote it all over and over
and over again and every time I would go
through it I would say it needs more
what what did you think what did you
feel at the time and so I just put it in
and it's as it's about as honest as I
can be his Millie read this yeah yeah
and she likes everything except the last
chapter which of course is the chapter
that talks about it's called losing
Millie and you know and it's it's a
horrible chapter I mean it there is no
end to it because you've got and and
fortunately I mean the way I think the
way the chapter ends no I guess I
changed it there was one point at which
Millie said well let me back up there
was one point at which I thought I'm
based on what Millie was telling me that
she wanted me to go find the
stuff that she was gonna use to kill
herself you know and which meant that I
would have to mix the potion right the
final exit means do you know the book
final exit potion second all Nembutal
something like that and I was terrified
and a friend of ours said you know don't
do that and millions really didn't
million was determined that she was
gonna kill herself that she was not
gonna go have a feeding - and this
friend of ours said you know have you
talked to a hospice do you know do you
know anything about hospice care and and
so I went to see the Washington home and
they said you know basically if she's
determined that she's not gonna get a
feeding tube basically she can starve
herself to death you know and just not
take any food and not take any water and
that'll be it so we had a will drawn up
and all this kind of stuff that she
could do that if that's what she wanted
to do but the latest the good news is is
that the latest time I've we've had a
conversation about this she said that
she would take a feeding tube so she
said as long as I can take it out when I
want to take it out so nonetheless the
last chapter is about all of this and
about you know what's gonna happen and
about you know dying is what it's about
and and obviously it's a depressing
chapter for her I mean it is for me too
but you say that she cries a lot and you
don't cry very much she doesn't cry as
much as she used to when she and and I
think her antidepressant is the reason
she she doesn't really cry very much at
all she's she's on an antidepressant
called effexor which puts a basically
puts a pan under her emotions and and
when she was first diagnosed she was
shattered she she had been a she and
Irene Poland Abe the wife of a Poland
the sports entrepreneur had a practice
together at
the neurology center up in Bethesda
Maryland and she had treated Parkinson's
patients and their families as a
psychiatric social worker and knew what
how devastating Parkinson's was so when
she got the diagnosis she was shattered
and and she assumed the worst and she
wept constantly and eventually I mean
prozac didn't work Zoloft and or xanax
didn't work but effects are a so she's
she cries a lot less I I cry sometimes
but I it's I don't know why I don't I I
just don't I mean I I guess because I'm
a guy I don't know did you have any
trouble right in the book from that
standpoint most ly no I don't think so
I had no there wasn't there was nothing
that was I can't remember ever thinking
this is too hard to write I mean I think
I kept saying to myself I've got to
write this and I've got to write it
better and I've got to write a truer and
I got to write it deeper but I mean
there was I mean there was one there was
one moment which was not writing that it
was I cry more at happy moments than I
do it terribly sad moments one of the we
went to this wedding which I in Chicago
which was the daughter of one of
Millie's old high school pals and
simultaneously with the wedding party is
off here and Millie's having this
reunion with all of her high school
friends and one after another they start
telling Millie stories about the great
things that she'd done in the
working-class neighborhood in
in Chicago back in the 50s and you know
just story after story after story after
story of how she you know people
wouldn't have gotten married had it not
been for Millie Millie stood up you know
in gang fights quote-unquote gang fights
you know she was a skinny little kid but
she was the one who didn't run away and
stuff like that a just story after story
after story after story and just these
stories made me cry just because because
of what one wonderful person she was and
is you know and that that's the kind of
thing that makes me cry it's tributes
make me cry where'd you meet her in
Chicago what year 1966 I believe we got
married 1967 that I know we had this
friend who was the spokeswoman for the
for the civil rights movement in Chicago
and was a pal of Millie's at Roosevelt
University and they were sort of
anti-war activists together and Joan her
name was Joan Kehoe then it's Joan Smith
now she's at the University of Vermont
she's a Dean at the University of
Vermont now
and so she fixed us up for a dinner date
it was not love love at first sight on
either side but but Millie was pretty
and she was sort of olive-skinned and
slow eyed and and prematurely gray and
she was really cute and she was
interesting and so we started dating and
you know it was as I confess in the book
I was a Dartmouth graduate I thought the
guy that I wanted to be as a big-shot
Washington journalist should be married
to somebody who went to Vassar whose
grandfather maybe was a Supreme Court
justice and I sort of held it against
Millie stupidly that she was a kind of a
wrong side of the tracks
Mexican half Mexican half Jewish kid who
used bad grammar sometimes and and if
she just overwhelmed all that you know
when I've been a happily married ever
since what were you doing then I was a
reporter for the Chicago sun-times in
Chicago first entry up in Chicago we do
that I was between Chicago and
Springfield and then covering
national politics out of Chicago five
years from 63 to 68 and came to
Washington 68 why did you think he
wanted to be a big-shot Washington
journalist because I was a journalist
you know and I wanted to be I wanted to
come to Washington and I wanted to be a
big-shot you know that I always wanted
to be some sort of I mean I thought my
hero was James Reston I carried his
picture around in my wallet he was the
Washington bureau chief of the New York
Times and you know I I had big ambitions
you know and it took a long time you
know to say there are other things in
life that are also important what did
you do after the sun-times I I was I
came to Washington for the sun-times and
worked there till 1977 was a White House
correspondent did a lot of traveling
overseas and then went to the New
Republic where I was for from 77 to 85
85 right and then went to Newsweek as
Washington bureau chief for 18 miserable
months and then went back to the New
Republic and then went to roll call
where I am happily now in the middle of
the Newsweek example you use in the book
you tell a story about going to mrs.
Catherine Graham's house you liked it
and Millie didn't I
yeah Millie Millie thought that Millie
Millie did not think I should go to
Newsweek in the beginning she liked the
New Republic she liked what I wrote at
the New Republic I wrote long pieces I
you know there I was it was thoughtful
and all that kind of stuff
and she knew better than I knew that I'm
not a manager and I'm not a politician
and I'm not a ego Saveur and I you know
that I that and you know so she wanted
me to stay at the New Republic she was
against the Newsweek thing from the
beginning but I was ambitious and I
thought you know that I could be editor
of Newsweek someday and I mean part of
the job was to
show up at mrs. Graham's dinner parties
you know and and it's an honor mrs.
Graham is a very nice lady the dinner
parties are terrific there you know you
meet interesting people the most
important people in the world could pass
through mrs. Graham's living room Billy
one had a Social Work practice that she
was doing at night - she had teenage
daughters and three she didn't like it
didn't like this you know beyond being a
beck and call of the of mrs. Graham so
she didn't she just didn't show up very
often and I you know I yelled at her
about it and she just said look I have
other things I have to do so that that's
the kind of person knowing what Millie
did what Nellie wanted to do when is the
first moment you knew that something was
wrong and that she had something that
led to Parkinson's we used to go to
Vermont every at Christmas time with
gaggle of relatives and friends and we
were filling out a college application
for one of our daughters and Millie was
actually writing that filling lots of
applications out on drea and Millie said
there's something wrong with the when I
write the letter K there's something
wrong with it
and I looked at it and I didn't see
anything wrong with it and she's a
something's wrong with it she wrote her
name several times that I can't make a
cave right that was the first sign what
year it was 1987 Christmas 1987 right
and then she developed a tremor in her
little finger of her right hand and she
went to the neurology Center where she
worked and they at first diagnosed ulnar
neuropathy which is a pinched nerve
basically and she did exercises and
stuff that didn't work and her the
tremor kept getting worse and finally
they gave her a Parkinson's medicine
without telling her that it was a
Parkinson's medicine and she took it and
I don't know whether I can't remember
whether it did any good or not but
eventually I guess it didn't
oh no that oh that what happened then
was that she looked it up that's right
she looked it up in her pill book and
pill catalog and she and she called me
up one day and she said you've got to
come home something terrible has
happened and she was weeping and sobbing
and she said the medicine they gave me
is for Parkinson's disease I know what
Parkinson's disease is it's horrible I
won't be able to eat I won't be able to
talk I'll choke to death you won't love
me anymore you'll leave me you know it
was she was hysterical and and you know
I did my best to calm her down she said
you don't know what Parkinson's is and
indeed I didn't know what Parkinson's is
that was sometime in 1988 and we shopped
around for diagnoses and finally we went
to the Mayo Clinic twice actually
and they diagnose Parkinson's disease
that's that's but you know she did her
best to avoid the diagnosis and and the
poor doctor who who had been her boss
dr. corngold very nice guy at the
neurology center she said I hate him
I'll never see him again it djay hasn't
seen him again she I mean it blamed him
for how many hospitals has she been in
um she's been at NIH she's been in Emory
twice obviously she's been at the
National Rehabilitation Hospital
I mean emergency rooms countless you
know she would
whatever the worst symptom that she had
was she just her balance just
disappeared
her sense of balance and she would fall
fall on her face fall on her side for it
she was banged up she had surgery I mean
she had stitches in her lips such as
stitches in her nose stitches on her
cheek stitches on her eyebrows and stuff
like that the Suburban Hospital in
Maryland Sibley Georgetown every time we
go on vacation she'd be in an emergency
room and you know you'd have these
experiences where the nurse would sort
of asked me to leave
to question her about spousal abuse you
know after a while they you know got
used to us so they knew that it
obviously wasn't but so a lot of
hospitals at some point in all this you
got a call from Howard Kurtz
yeah the Washington Post the media
writer right what was it about well I
had I in order to double to try to
increase the parkinson's budget NIH
spends about it's a disputed figure but
let's say roughly now about $50 per
victim per year on Parkinson's disease
research they spend like a thousand
dollars a year per victim on an HIV
victim 400 on a cancer victim I mean
there's great disparity so there what I
what I did was I mean there are two ways
to go one is to is to go directly and
try to increase the parkinson's budget
which i tried to do to do and did some
some lobbying at crucial point and then
i helped found an organization called
nih - and it was a organization that
also did some lobbying on behalf of
doubling the NIH budget over a five-year
period and a prep and I was the host at
a press conference where Connie Mack Tom
Harkin and Fred upped and Henry Waxman
and John Porter and a bunch of other
people were complaining about the latest
Clinton budget and somebody sent the
announcement of the press release off to
Howie Kurtz Howie Kurtz is the media
critic of the Washington Post and Howie
Kurtz called me up and said you know
you're a journalist what are you doing
working with a lobbying organization and
I said look I believe in this cause and
I don't care who complains well he
printed that the paper the next thing
you know the superintendent at the press
gallery the Senate press gallery calls
up and says look lobbying
is not it's against the rules and it is
it is against the movies and it should
be against the rules and he said you've
got to either give it up or you're gonna
lose your press card your press
credentials and so I gave it up and my
lobbying career is fundamentally come to
an end but it brings up the issue of you
know since you've gotten involved in
this
you've gone directly to politicians and
ask for money from the government for
this problem that brings up to George
Bush story in the middle of the campaign
what did you do well with George boy
George Bush I I don't know that you
could call it exactly call it lobbying
and well and it was just about as
ham-handed and an effort as I'd been
with Clinton at the Christmas party but
basically we were it was in the it was
at WMUR in Manchester New Hampshire
right before the New Hampshire primary
in 2000 and he was taking off his makeup
in a makeup room after a Fox News
interview and I said can I write you a
letter about my favorite cause and he
said what's that and I said doubling the
NIH budget and he said I'm for it and
then I said well think about brain
research and he said brain cancer and I
said no and then I then I made a total
botch of this what I was trying to do
was to get him to think about increasing
the budget for all kinds of brain
research I was not making a specific
pitch for Parkinson's I was not lobbying
for a specific bill I was saying you
know this is an exciting area I'm meant
to say this is a truly exciting frontier
area of knowledge that deserves to get
more help and I wasn't gonna come in for
any specific numbers or anything like
that
and basically I didn't deliver a good
speech that the it was if it was a
30-second conversation in which he
reaffirmed that he was in favor of the
NIH doubling did he do it well he's
almost done it I mean he said he would
do it and he his budget calls for 13
three percent increase in NIH which is
healthy but it's not a ramp to double it
would take sixteen point five percent
now his OMB director says that he will
make it up next year but clearly the tax
cut has limited his NIH request as well
as his other spending what are the
ethics of using your platform to lobby
in the public arena for more money for
this research
look I this is my wife's life you know
there was a felt need I mean a good
clear injustice this was something that
that ought to be done that needed to be
done what I ultimately did was I wrote
columns about it and I disclosed what I
that my wife had Parkinson's disease and
why I was doing this and stuff I think
that intervening on behalf of specific
legislation at specific times is
something I should not have done by the
rules it is using my it was using my
special access as a journalist to on
behalf of a cause if it could be used
for that cause it could be used for any
cause you know good or bad and it that I
and it shouldn't be done you know people
shouldn't do it and once called on it I
stopped doing it you show us behind the
scenes a little bit on Capitol Hill when
they bring in stars like Michael J Fox
what happens and also the egos of the
committee members you tell a Arlen
Specter story yeah I mean Arlen Specter
has been exposed exposed by other people
for for doing this I mean some people
just you know are like to have started
and it and look if you're a chairman of
a committee you want to attract
publicity for whatever it whatever
hearing you
are holding and getting a star there to
talk gets the cameras and Senator
Specter go does it more than than most
and more successfully than most and he's
had Michael J Fox there and Christopher
Reeve there and Mary Tyler Moore and I
can't think of them oh but but other
people other people do it too they've
gotten art or you know general
Schwarzkopf to talk about prostate
cancer and they get Jessica Lange to
talk about farms and stuff like you know
it's it's a common it's a common
practice on Capitol Hill and you know
senator Specter shouldn't be
particularly singled out for it although
you know he's more adept at it than most
people there's one thing out in this
book that I that I want that I want to
correct if I could I said in the book
that John McCain during the South
Carolina primary apologized for his
having changed his position on fetal
tissue research and I heard a an
appearance of his on this week with Sam
Donaldson an interview with Sam
Donaldson in which he sort of made an
apologetic remark about it and I forgot
the rest of it and I've gone back to
look at the transcript John McCain's
office having called me about all this
and indeed in context in the whole
context he didn't apologize for what
he'd done so as far as I'm concerned I
mean I John McCain did chicken out on on
stem cell research which is a currently
pending issue but on fetal tissue
research which was a former fight he
didn't back to the artists story for a
moment what I really was getting at was
the story about him stomping out of the
room because yes Ted Kennedy wanted to
go over head of the rest of them and
what was that all about well this was a
previous press conference to the to the
one involving Howie Kurtz we had
Christopher Reeve this was before
Michael J Fox disclosed that he had
Parkinson's and Christopher even Mary
Tyler Moore came for a press conference
on NIH funding and again I was the host
of that and and
Connie Mack and and Tom Harkin spoke
first and the question was who was gonna
speak next and Senator Kennedy grabbed
my sleeve and said can I talk I got to
get out of here
that's how I said yes and so I interview
introduced senator Kennedy next and all
of a sudden senator Specter disappeared
from the room there was a hubbub and
Senator Specter stalked out and one of
and his health aide grabbed one of the
other people who was involved in NIH -
and sort of throttles her not seriously
I mean didn't strangle her but you know
got mad at her and said senator Kennedy
is he the chairman and and I delivered a
deeply apologetic obsequious letter to
Senator Specter apologizing for this
light but in future in future cases
senator Specter was fine with a story of
congressman bill young and Michael J Fox
and the family Mike who by the way is
just as great a human being in person as
he appears to be on television he is
than the neatest guy anyway he came to
testify before senator Specter and then
made the rounds around the hill and
practically every office that he went
into you know everybody had to have a
photograph with him and Senator Lott
wanted photographs and all the visitors
and Senator Lots office wanted
photographs with him and all so on then
he went over to chairman Young's office
Bill Young is the chairman of the Senate
of the House Appropriations Committee
and mrs. young had I think a whole bunch
of children and their friends and stuff
like that and they all had to have
pictures - I mean it's if you're Michael
J Fox people want to have your picture
yeah I have pictures taken with him had
congressman Young's family is no
different you reveal in the book about
your own reaction to being in a public
place with your wife and realizing that
people would look at you and say
Kandra he's a great guy because look at
him out there on the dance floor with
his wife he's dealing with all this very
well why did you tell us that well and
did you want people to say isn't he a
good guy yeah well yeah there was a
point I mean I'm I've changed on this
there was a point at which I wanted
people I wanted to get the credit for
being the loyal attentive husband that I
was being you know I wanted people to
notice for ego purposes I guess and you
know and people used to say you know
Mort you're a saint and I used to sort
of exalt in that and I've been I've been
I said good I'm getting credit for it
I've dispensed with that I mean it does
not say that I don't want people to
appreciate that I'm doing the best I can
but real life is more important than
what people think about stuff like that
so I I mean we still dance at weddings I
mean really loves to dance but and I
know the people are looking and I know
that people are saying gee isn't that
great but it's the doing it that's the
most fulfilling thing not what not what
people think I mean it's just part of
growing up I guess what are they gonna
say to you about this book do you think
I hope they'll be very moved by it I
hope they will help us you know double
triple the Parkinson's budget and beat
this disease they help us beat this
disease
how long does Millie have I think a
feeding tube decision where when she's
not gonna be able to swallow is a year I
think and she's how old she's 61 and
then if she takes if she if she takes
feeding - it'll be it that's indefinite
but the problem is is that I don't know
what kind of life she's gonna have
I mean whether the mo Udall thing is I
mean part of more you dolls problem was
is that he had this brain concussion and
he couldn't couldn't talk I mean she is
all there you know she is she has a far
better memory than I do and she knows
what's going on now for her to be
trapped inside her body is is horrendous
you know and that's the future that I
fear the most for her but I but I don't
know I don't know I I don't know how
long it how long it is
I mean mo Udall was in that position for
seven years I don't know how long she's
gonna want to be in that position I
don't know that she's gonna want to be
in that visitor I don't know how this
story ends this is the book saving
Mellie our guest has been Mort Kondracke
thank you very much thanks